hi
i'm stephen boyd i'm one of the
co-authors
of the book introduction to applied
linear algebra
vectors matrices and least squares i
teach the course
uh engineering 108 engr 108 at stanford
uh leaving vandenberg my co-author also
teaches a course
ee 133 at ucla
so these are the these are the the um
these lectures are gonna follow the
slides um
which in turn followed the book very
closely so
uh that's and before we jump into the
details i'm just gonna spend a couple
minutes right now and talk about how you
might
use the material you know how you might
use these lectures and
the book and other stuff so i'll say a
little a few things about that
well the first i should say is something
about the prerequisites about what
what you need to know uh to do this
course or for that matter to read the
book and
get get the most out of it actually very
little
um so we will use a little bit of
calculus a few times
uh in the course but to be honest it's
it's not like it's uh
that's a that's a giant prerequisite um
another one and i'll talk much more
about this in a bit is um
you should you should have seen some
simple uh programming
uh in in essentially any language um
i'll say a lot more about that you do
not have to be like an expert programmer
uh you don't have to take in maybe a
whole full course on computer science
um but you do have to know a little bit
um and i'll
i'll say more about that later
okay so let me say uh about how
i i think you can use these resources so
one one resource is the book
i should mention that the book is
actually just available online you just
go to google or your favorite search
engine you'll find it pretty quick
the pdf file of the book um
and that's uh that's courtesy of
cambridge university press who
we're open-minded enough to allow us to
post the book online which i think is
wonderful
um in fact i even use the book online as
well i have
obviously hard copy but i use it online
too because there's links and you can
jump from one place to another and
search
so just everyone should be aware the
book is online
uh also online you'll find these slides
the slides that i'm gonna cover
um and eventually you're gonna find uh
these lectures as
as well are gonna be uh online uh so
posted for anybody in the world uh to to
watch um okay so let me say a little bit
about these
the the the different um resources and
and how i think
um what the best you know what what
might be a good way for you to learn
so first of all the book is is complete
so you
can read the book and you can read it
like a conventional book in other words
you could uh
you know read a chapter and you know
whatever i mean
it's readable i think so you can just
read it um and in fact that's a that's
a good thing to do uh you know so it may
not be a take it to the beach book but
it is kind you know maybe kind of a
of a windy and cold afternoon uh reading
book could could be
perfectly good for that just just the
book just read it turn the pages page to
page
um and it it's of course the most
detailed
it's got pretty much everything uh in is
in there
so you know that that's what that's
where you'd want and we're very careful
in our language in the book relatively
careful
um the slides are well of course they
are a condensation of the book so they
are more terse um in some ways there's
there's something like the essence
of the book now not everything is there
so we don't
carefully define every every notation
and things like that in the slides
but the idea is it's supposed to be at a
maybe a 5 000 foot level
uh what what the course looks like and
finally there are these lectures right
and you might ask you know
why would i listen to someone read the
lectures i can read perfectly well
myself
that's true and so the lectures are even
more informal than the slides
it's me and what you get in the lectures
is uh
gossip i might tell stories about
various aspects
something like that um of course it's
not it's not complete
uh you know the the lectures uh and you
can't hold me to
uh you know everything won't be perfect
and i i may not defend
i might not define everything and all
that sort of stuff um
so that that's sort of so how these
three resources work for you
um i think that that's very personal
depends on the person some people
like to read like a chapter at a time
then look at the slides
uh maybe watch the lecture maybe the
other way around watch the lecture first
totally up to you actually honestly i
think all of these methods uh these work
um this brings me to something very very
important
um and that's this that the material
that we're going to be covering in that
we cover in the book
is super interesting and it is super
useful
and in fact one of the one of the most
important parts about it is that
it's all actionable it's not just theory
i mean it is theory this beautiful
theory
that we're gonna that we're gonna look
at but the but the really cool part
about it is
you can do it it is actually empowering
and it enables you to do all sorts of
crazy stuff
um you can fit models uh
like in machine learning we'll see other
types of things you can do we can do
signal processing where you can extract
a signal from a noisy signal
you can you can do all sorts of stuff
you can
model well you can model epidemics for
example using some of the material
that we're going to look at in in the
course so you can do a whole lot of
stuff
and it's very important in in my opinion
it's very important that you follow
along the book
and the course uh doing numerical
exercises in some
computer language um and even if that's
not your interest
uh even if you're interested just to
learn the theory let's say
um this helps enormously because it it
will actually just
it'll help you go over in a different
way and understand in a different way
the topics we're talking about so you
know if i
show you an identity uh in you know an
equation that is supposed to always hold
don't believe me just go to your
favorite computer program
type in you know type in uh something on
the type in the left hand side type in
the red hand
right hand side and they should be they
should agree or be very very close
numerically right so this is
it's really uh great uh to that i would
strongly recommend
even though it's not necessary you can
read the book from be covered at cover
and we actually mention in the book no
specific computer language
um and i think you could actually i mean
it'd be it'd be fine
that that would be treating it as a
conventional math book but i think you'd
really be wasting
um an important uh opportunity here
uh which is that the material of this
course is actually actionable you can
actually do it
or i like to say this linear algebra
should not be
a spectator sport so jump in there
get your hands dirty fire up one of
these tools and uh follow along that way
i think that
that'll help a lot um i should add
that's gonna be super important uh when
you
you know if you end up doing a summer
internship or something like that where
you use these things
it's one thing to know the material in
this book it's quite another to be able
to
sit down and actually do something with
it which is very very cool
um so let me say a little bit about
languages so in at the stanford course
uh we
we happen to use julia that's a that's a
relatively new
uh language and yeah the reason is it
it works super well but it's also it's
the one that maybe
has the notation that is kind of closest
uh to ours um another one
that is an option is matlab uh now
that's proprietary meaning that you'd
have to
have to pay for it but it is a perfectly
good option to follow along with the
ideas uh in in this course
um and the last another option um
is python uh python is an interesting
option and i do know that some people
are teaching this course
teaching a course based on the book and
they're using python and it's actually a
perfectly good choice and the reason is
that
most people these days are using python
to do
the kinds of stuff that you're going to
learn about in this course so in some
sense it makes sense for you to
uh to start start off um with
the uh with the language that you'd
actually use in your internship or your
job or your startup
so that would be the argument behind
python my
only reason for not selecting python in
my own course
is that the syntax is a little bit uh
clunky and it deviates a little bit from
the from the mathematical syntax
not in a terribly horrible way but it
just seemed to me that julia
uh the julia language syntax fit
the ideas just a little bit better but
anyway
overall though i would strongly urge you
to uh to follow along this course
with us with doing some numerical
examples
now the book itself does not refer uh or
refers only a few times
to uh computation it does describe a
little bit about computation but
we don't mention any specific computer
language in the book
um there will be a few extras there are
a few exercises in the book where we say
go ahead and
check us out see if you really believe
this or evaluate this two different ways
or something like that
um so we have that's that that's that we
certainly have
uh but um
with the uh you'll also find uh some
kind of you know real world-ish examples
um
and if you go to uh the website for the
book uh it's gonna point to
uh a set of exercises uh called
additional exercises and these are
dynamically updated each year
in those exercises unlike the exercises
of the book those actually
include problems with real data so it'll
even
you'll find it at the website you'll
you'll find a bunch of data files and
you can do some you can do some finance
some portfolio construction you can do
tomography and things like that
you can fit some models make a
prediction or something like that
and i think that's an important part of
the course okay well i guess
that finishes up this preliminary and
what we'll do
next is we're just going to jump right
in